command the Seas with history's most
iconic war vessels in the latest
free-to-play combat game world of
warships download now hey guys it is
Friday which means I've got five of this
week's biggest stories in gaming to get
you all caught up on what's been going
on
hopefully somebody at Activision got a
talking to this week as it seems someone
thought it was a good idea to live-tweet
a fake terrorist attack from the
verified call of duty Twitter account
the account swap this picture and
display name to make it appear as a
legitimate news outlet and then posted a
series of tweets detailing an apparent
explosion in Marina Bay Singapore that
resulted in a state of emergency and
authorities declaring Martial Law the
move was intended to promote call of
duty black ops 3 and its story whether
or not people fell for it many found the
marketing ploy to be in poor taste in
less ludicrous news depending on your
perspective a man proposed to his
girlfriend during a destiny livestream
twitch stream an escort fires dog into
the room with a proposal hung around his
neck and that's when her boyfriend pops
the question where do you think this is
adorable or stupid I think we can all
agree that this is likely the only
proposal ever to take place while
hovering over the Grim citizen three
auto rifle oh and she said yes we're at
the start of a brand new month which
means more brand new free games that of
course with your PS plus or xbox live
subscription PlayStation fans can pick
up birkin age and Susie meet voice of
ps4 and Vita and chariot for ps3 coming
to both ps4 and ps3 are unmechanical
extended rhythm game kickbeat and action
game kung fu rabbit these games will be
available from october six but it's also
worth noting that the drive club
playstation plus edition will cease to
be available on that day so grab it
before it's gone if xbox is your jam you
can get metal gear solid 5 ground zeroes
for free on xbox 360 in the first half
of the month and tell tells The Walking
Dead through the second half on xbox 360
and
Xbox one also available on Xbox one is
the wonderful valiant heart the Great
War which you can pick up all month long
that damn ps4 update we've been talking
about for what feels like forever
finally came out this week and here's
the short of what you'll get in it the
3.0 update will let you share video
clips to Twitter access a dedicated
section 2 PlayStation Plus games live
stream directly to YouTube from your ps4
and create or join communities which are
built around shared interest
improvements have also been made some
messages and groups in addition to an
increase in online storage for PS plus
members from one gigabyte to 10
gigabytes finally PlayStation boss
Shuhei Yoshida has talked about the ps4
holiday lineup as compared to the xboxes
Microsoft is very keen on telling
everybody that it's holiday lineup this
year is the strongest in the history of
xbox and Suri has now said their piece
as well yes she does said he thinks Tony
blacking first party line up for the
rest of the year it's not the big
problem for the ps4 he told Eurogamer
people wouldn't just look at the first
party line up when they're making a
purchase decision we have great
third-party titles coming this year call
of duty black ops 3 Assassin's Creed
syndicate star wars battlefront destiny
the taken King just came out and metal
gear solid 5 de phantom pain just came
out there's no shortage of huge titles
available to players on playstation 4
and people who are coming new to
PlayStation 4 can pick up titles like
blood-borne and untold
on I'm very proud of the games we are
releasing Yoshida said he believes
people will make console purchasing
decisions for the long term oh he isn't
worried about it be sure to have that
comment sections let me know what you
cared about from this week this week on
site I tell you about free-to-play games
that are actually worth your time on the
gist we test out the NBA 2k16 face
gaming feature and Lucy talks about
wargaming on in two minutes that is
everything I have you this week as
always be sure to have yourself a lovely
weekend and I will catch you again on
Monday